hey everybody it's Monday yeah sorry if
you can hear all that noise in the
background that's oh it just stops
that's nice somebody doing yardwork I
don't know I can't figure out like when
yard work is I think our people are here
Friday but then they have like our
neighborhood has got everybody
everybody's neighbor the neighbors yeah
that's that's a private that's him out
there with the lawnmower yeah of course
yeah and this like the Windows is right
there but yeah so anyway it's Monday we
just decided to a little sidetrack show
didn't have anything particular in stock
box we were actually gonna watch a new
movie last night to review but then we
didn't end up I was like too tired to
watch anything then we ended up watching
like an old one which I'm not gonna
spoil that'll be the movie retrospective
this week we did actually start watching
the first episode I can't bust in she's
like those doors why you guys they here
closing on the door you can't do yeah we
didn't actually start watching the first
episode of series last night I guess it
just went up and I think it was like
number 10 like in on Netflix you know in
the US or whatever and it was called
what was it called southern survival
yeah something like that
it was kind of like Mythbusters but rock
a redneck style like Mythbusters meets
duck dynasty yeah what they were doing
is they have some they have some kind of
uh I guess it's an online stores price
yeah it's a battle box battle box and
they they test all these suckin
survivalist products yeah and then they
take the best ones and they put them in
their store and the first episode was
about fire they were looking for [ __ ]
that makes fire and fire retardant stuff
they had a flamethrower and they were
[ __ ] shoots different kinds of clothes
and clothing to see what would catch on
fire it was I thought was gonna be
better
it wasn't like well I think the thing
about it and I think this is something
that why Mythbusters was so beloved and
like you know why you know tried to kind
of rip
that formula and were not successful I
think the whole thing about Mythbusters
was that you know the two guys were you
know the chemistry between them was so
good and then they had like those three
other people so you kind of went back
and forth it was like a lot of you know
there was kind of a lot of variety in
the show this one I feel like it's not
so much it's not bad it's just that I
don't like the dudes at the center of it
are not like all that charismatic no and
you can tell that they're kind of trying
to be funny and it's like not and all
that funny another thing is just that
there wasn't anything really
particularly like redneck about that's
true I know a lot and [ __ ] worse than
that you got a maid yeah Mississippi I
know some guys that could really do that
they were kind I would call him fake
rednecks it's just that they weren't the
old school ones yeah I mean they were
like they grew up with the Internet yeah
that's not really that isn't cow you
can't rednecks don't have it in an
Internet I mean you know in the sense
that rednecks do you like to blow [ __ ]
up I mean you know everyone knows that
but I do feel like I mean the whole
thing about the thing behind the show
though is that this is their business
like I said it's kind of like duck
dynasty in that way where it's just like
their business is to you know test I
guess you know survival type products
and so they just kind of built a show
around that which you know that could
work I know I enjoy watching people blow
stuff up as much as the next person but
I just I don't know maybe it'll get
better cuz we only watched the first one
and I was it was only like half an hour
and I was like and then sounds like now
I'm gonna go play a video yeah and I
started watching dark again it was the
cast I mean yeah like I said they seem
like nice dudes but they didn't seem
like all that compelling no well first
of all they weren't know that they
weren't very physically fit yeah yeah I
mean so they're trying to test these
these products they were just kind of
like although he did kind of laugh at
that dude trying to climb out of town
yeah out of the fire isn't like a
firefighter tower like the cool repel it
can do anything
it couldn't couldn't do anything that it
seemed
have any like true survival skills you
know or any kind of military background
or even woodsmen our Huntsman
backgrounds they're just maybe in that
well maybe in that way that's kind of
like they're appealing to their customer
base because maybe that's who their
customer base is is like kind of out of
shape dudes that just like want
something yeah like help them if they're
somehow trapped out they don't throw a
burning building or something but I was
like I think if they're in a burning
building they're gonna be a big trouble
cuz they could barely I just I just
don't think I just don't I just don't
see real [ __ ] if you ask me I mean I was
growing up around my like my dad's
friends and my dad's friends not so much
my dad but my dad's friends some of
those dudes are like [ __ ] Daryl and
Merle Dixon they're like that yeah you
know the [ __ ] dudes have tried to
make a living making a living trapping
[ __ ]
living in a house that they've been
living in for like three generations it
looks like looks like covered in mold
and [ __ ] on the outside looks like a
leather Facebooker maybe the Jason
Bourne yeah yeah yeah and they just they
don't want jobs I mean they just don't
want if I can yeah they just they can do
it off link I live off the land and live
off working for other people fixing
motorboats fix them fixing outboard
motors [ __ ] you know I mean
shade-tree mechanic stuff that's that's
how they would make their live and they
didn't want to work working for somebody
else boss and [ __ ] no they didn't didn't
play that no they grew up in the area
sir buddy knew him so they were
constantly getting jobs yeah here man
fix this here do this hey go help me
build this and they show up you know
yeah but they didn't need paychecks and
jobs and [ __ ] I was there for [ __ ]
it was like the I will say that one
thing that about this show was that I
will say that the the matches they
tested like there's really good matches
yeah yes I didn't know that they had
those they will not go out there big
like there big man yeah there's a match
about that long and you could strike it
I guess it was made out of phosphorus it
would burn on her water yeah underwater
yeah and they did like wind they did
like the [ __ ] you know the fire
extinguisher on it I was
dad I was going like yeah and buy like a
pack of 500 of those and bundle this all
together and say I'm Cece the CDC Pike
don't you have a [ __ ] ready-made
incendiary to [ __ ] grenade throw that
through somebody's window you'll never
put that [ __ ] out no I'm just saying I
could weaponize it but it seemed really
useful like if you're going camping or
something like that cuz if they got wet
or you know if there was if it was wind
in or rain or something like that yeah
that's kind of a fallacy though you know
like you can't start a fire when it's
Footwear's right cuz all the [ __ ]
well because all the woods woods wet
yeah and only a pussy's gonna need a
fire anyway forgot I had to live for
[ __ ] weeks without fire think about
it now the field [ __ ] would fire you
without fire you know we didn't we
couldn't have fire all the time because
sometimes when we were in the army but a
lot of times it was a little chemical
heaters that we cooked MREs in yeah you
don't really need fire though yeah
not all unless you have to unless you're
you've got raw meat you have to cook
well yeah that's what you don't really
need it or unless you could just wait
for the rain to stop yeah you know it's
not normal living where you had to have
three squares a day you just wait just
wait
you're not gonna starve I'm gonna star
if you just sleep wouldn't know until
the rainbabies look at those people on
naked and afraid they're on there too
like three weeks without eating anything
yeah I mean they lose a bunch of weight
but then that's the name of the game
they die no um yeah but so I'm just
saying those matches were neat and they
seem like they're really useful the
other stuff not so much just well the
other eye the other thing that they had
was like something if you were trapped
in a burning building I guess it was
like a little breather thing and it had
like an flashlights honours yeah it was
like a it's like a thing you put in your
mouth for boxing like like yeah like
something like a mouth guard came out
but it was like the two of you ler yeah
but it's like a tube that came out of
that and then it went to a filter you
can keep it by the bed so if the house
ever got filled with smoke from a fire
you could put it in your mouth like a
like a like a gas mask but you know
masks just a filter in your mouth yeah
that would be good enough to get out of
the house yeah I mean it was blind
though yeah it wasn't like long-term
oxygen it was only like supposed to be
long
to get you out of it and it had like a
light on it so you could like see
through the [ __ ] yeah the filter was
probably a little bit bigger than a
d-cell battery yeah so probably clogged
up pretty quick but it'd be enough to
get you out of house that's what I was
thinking it's like you probably only
have like a few minutes of but you know
I guess I'd be better than nothing
yeah but yeah so we only watched one
episode of that and like I said I was
like I don't know I just couldn't get
into it and um neither so she's drunk at
he'll he's drunk as hell and we pop up
at his feed says it's the best day ever
[Laughter]
no they blew up some they blew up a
bunch of stuff mannequins like I said
they're kind of taking their cue from
Mythbusters yes if we saw the jewel on
Ceres we just saw that it was up there
we yeah we're I'm actually that's might
be one of the next ones i watch because
um I kind of wanted to review that cuz I
did like the jawan movies I even liked
the American remake it was okay um I
didn't like didn't we see wasn't there a
new movie that was like a remake or
something it's just like I can't even
remember it was only a few months ago we
saw it in the theater I think it was
like do you honored something and it
just and it wasn't good so he didn't
fourth drawer doom that fourth drawer
down is asking if we've ever seen the
breather device that goes down the
toilet I have never seen that why the
hell would you want to bring down a
toilet in case you're going I never
thought that I would ever hear the
sentence we're gonna breathe through the
toys [ __ ] there's another shirt let's
breathe through the toilet
you need some breath mints after that
one yeah I guess so give some nasty-ass
respiratory infections breathing in all
that [ __ ] dust Doris that's nasty
yeah but yeah so I definitely do want to
watch the Juwan series next like I said
I'm trying to get through season one and
two of dark again so I can watch season
three like the new one but
for a ie I went to the Wikipedia page
didn't like no I can't cuz I didn't want
to see what happened I just got to I'm
still on season 1 because like I said
season 1 is like the longest it's like 8
episodes within like 2 & 3 I think of
only four episodes each because I think
they're like an hour long right and I
only just got to the part in the first
season again where it spoiler alert if
you haven't seen it where where Jonas
finds out that Mikkel the kid that
disappeared in his timeline went back to
1985 and is actually his own dad and I
had totally forgotten about that because
I saw it a long time ago and I only
remembered like the bare outlines of
like the you know the 33 year cycle and
all of that and I had totally forgotten
about that revelation and like when I
saw it again less and I was like that he
was that kid
it's like [ __ ] crazy you know it's
funny because I went to the Wikipedia
page and somebody has made like not only
do they have a list of like all of the
you know families and who's related to
who and everything cuz it's like four
different interlocking families and
people somebody also made this big like
chart of like all the interlocking
timelines of like all the [ __ ] and I'm
like holy crap somebody really went
hardcore with this yeah you know what I
mean speaking of rednecks and [ __ ] from
that program Oh bless you pokey I uh I
got some Mississippi news today you got
Mississippi Mississippi news there
changing the Mississippi State Flag they
have decided what its gonna be that's
gonna say In God We Trust on it they're
the the little state representatives and
they're gonna come up with a new platter
because the Mississippi flag state flag
for since the Civil War was like a
mixture of the Confederate flag and the
[ __ ] battle flag together it had the
battle flag on now people misses a lot
of people see that battle flag and call
it the Confederate flag that is not the
Confederate flag that was a battle flag
or one of the armies one of the
Confederate armies one with the the X
with the stars in it that it's not the
Confederate flag yeah that's a battle
flag anyway that was on it so they're
taking there they're gonna change the
flag because they said the
times have changed Videl yeah so just
saying that's they're also gonna change
the way like way Mississippi was
organized Mississippi kind of had would
he call him electoral votes like each
County had its own amount of electoral
votes and then together decided to the
who won an election inside the state
they're changing it down to a popular
vote from inside the state yeah because
it didn't make any damn sense because
the populations have all moved around
right and I had to do with after
construction because immediately a race
war broke out as soon as the [ __ ]
reconstruction happened and of course
white people were the minority so you
needed that damn electoral system to
[ __ ] make sure that the the slaves
didn't get in charge and [ __ ] kill
all the white people or whatever that's
what they were afraid of but they used
that to dominate the states for a while
until until [ __ ] white people's
population sprung back because they had
all [ __ ] been killed in this day of
concentration camps hear about that no
yeah most of those guys got captured yep
died in concentration camps a lot of
those Confederate soldiers they got
captured they didn't get released they
kept him until they died a lot of them
but they died of [ __ ] and this was
during during the war too you know they
were dying a [ __ ] diseases because
they were just stack them one on top of
the other anyway that's uh they're doing
that they got that done so it's just
wait to see what the Mississippi flag is
gonna be gonna say In God We Trust on it
though yeah I'm pretty sure the Florida
flag says that or something of our says
that I can't even remember now yeah but
uh yeah that's us laughing at that
comment that's how America got coded
nineteen breathing through the toilet
yeah that what we did god damn it
wouldn't surprise me you've got to tell
people not to do that but yeah so um
what else are we gonna oh um oh I have
to say that speaking of well it's not
really speaking of anything but speaking
of cooking and food you made a very
lovely shrimp masalas yeah and it's
delish
probably be better tomorrow mango
beggars asking how they could change
that flag I actually look man what they
said it makes a lot of sense really um
the flag Flags state flags change can
change quite often they usually reflect
the situation in the population of the
times originally that wasn't
Mississippi's flag that that was after
the war now they also said though that
they weren't going to remove Confederate
statues they said because that's that's
the history they said that was from the
past now some of them will probably go
to men to museums anyway but man it was
growing up part of the time at
Mississippi it was a [ __ ] weird place
Mississippi had a lot in common with
North Korea had North Korea was a
[ __ ] traumatized population by the
Korean War when Nate got done they just
became very insular when the war was
over North Korea because of course
became very insular and all he did is
sit around build monuments the South
kind of did that the South sat around
building monuments is like [ __ ] used to
the north it really didn't have anything
to do with black people had to do they
did not like [ __ ] the north at all so
every time they put up one of those can
those Confederate monuments it was
basically kind of like you're not the
boss of me that was that was the
mentality now this wasn't even my
grandparents generations it was although
that generation did a lot of it this
would be like my great-grandparents Jeff
thank you Matt thank you that did most
of that most of those people are on them
down Confederate statues the average
person doesn't even know who they are
they're just some dude you know you
might know who statue of some dude and
statue some dude yeah well a lot of
times it was some dude that was local
yeah I mean he wasn't really famous
outside that little town heidelberg has
a Confederate statue in it it was the
[ __ ] funniest thing in the world
because that was a basically a little
village and they must have pulled pulled
twenty thirty thousand dollars together
to put that damn monument up there
[ __ ] eighty years ago and that was a
lot of money back then and nobody Ardley
ever sees it it's probably about thirty
feet
I think that my probing you'd better
spend that's not the mentality they had
a [ __ ] you mentality they felt that
they're there that they didn't have an
identity and they needed to [ __ ] make
a monument to somebody they knew who
died in that war did something in that
war and that's just the it was like a
thing of defiance more than anything it
was just a defiance and it was defiance
against people in the north that hated
them because they were always kind of
hated it was you know anywhere we were
weird getting out I mean they were they
were they were weird people I remember
like our grandparents was kind of like
the last of them like I heard my
grandmother you know if anything was
from outside Mississippi then damn it
was [ __ ] wrong Infernus yeah from
outside Mississippi yeah she's from
where she's from Alabama
[Laughter]
I saw a Bama yeah yeah as a farce long
far away they liked Yankees in Alabama
like that yeah my grandparents said
Tennessee she from Tennessee and my
grandparents were from Tennessee yeah
Tennessee man names Yankees way up north
[ __ ] funny man it is very funny yeah
and they weren't dumb why people think
they were dumb they weren't they were
not dumb they were just low information
yeah and didn't give a [ __ ] they could
do math in their head and do all kinds
of [ __ ] [ __ ] but if if I spoke
Portuguese around my [ __ ] grandmother
one time her just [ __ ] jaw just
dropped open you speak dead
I said yeah you know I've lived in
Brazil you know she don't have livers
I didn't know you could really speak
that yeah because I'm not sure you
should be speaking that might become a
Brazilian what you might spontaneous all
of a sudden they might everybody that is
my Tim purify me okay yeah yeah it might
be a disrespect to my ancestors this is
never going to come back in ha yeah
this is not unusual you know South
Koreans were like that the South Koreans
are like that too they love you you know
the me but they they would marry you too
mama
they love you from like arms like the
end and Koreans are the same way yeah
Koreans are like southerners yeah North
Koreans are even worse well that's like
you said it's a very insular yes sir
traumatized culture it's you know it's
not as like that as much anymore because
like I said of the internet and
everything like that and like you said
it it's started to break down even
before that like if MTV yeah when
everybody started getting cable TV well
my dad wasn't like that but his parents
were like that my dad wasn't as much but
about half of his friends were yeah it
was just change it you know yeah um the
hell is that is that right brain holy Sh
yeah yeah that came out of nowhere
no Florida yeah glad you're still doing
shows we always do shows I tried it like
I said I try to put up something every
day whether it's you know we don't
always have time to like watch new
movies because I like to like review you
see I'm gonna get a Brazilian wax yes
Sandra said earlier that she checked I
was pretty sure the Florida flag did
have in god we trust' on it and indeed
it does tehrany Richardson says as a
black man from the South North Carolina
those statues don't bother me a lot of
those statues in red yeah they didn't
have anything to do with black people
they weren't insulting to black people
they were insulting to white northerners
that was a big [ __ ] you to those people
they didn't like them
it was inter white boy [ __ ] rivalry
white boy bitchery it was white boy
bitchery very common south of got it
south and gotten its ass kicked in it
for generations it just didn't forgive
and just didn't forgive them north well
yeah like I said my dad was still
talking about that [ __ ] and my dad was
born in the 50s my grandmother hated
northerners yeah hated them it was like
they were from and that they were an
invading [ __ ] army of foreigners
that's exactly as they yeah that's how
she saw very much probably based on what
I
have read probably kind of like the the
way the Irish felt about the English
yeah probably a lot like that maybe
worse I don't know you live there yeah
the art well the Irish in the English
really don't like each other the Welsh
in the English really don't like each
other either yeah so you know it's kind
of like not so much I don't know I don't
think when I was over there I never got
a real you know it was mostly just kind
of a teasing sort of thing like English
people would call the Welsh like sheep
shaggers and yeah like you know like
they were kind of backward but I just
like younger people I knew didn't really
have that attitude like I'm like it was
just like over here was there like an
older people think yeah
Civil War didn't destroy the south
didn't conquer the south what what
destroyed the south Thank You Nico what
destroyed the South was MTV yeah yeah as
soon as as soon as everybody in the
South you saw oh we're like yeah we want
to hear that we don't want to live yeah
Duran Duran they saw prints they saw a
[ __ ] who else you too how was your
class Culture Club southern [ __ ]
Southern culture couldn't compete with
that well yeah I know it wasn't
glamorous no gran was in South it wasn't
glamorous yeah living in the trailer
park yeah and having like shoes from
Kmart and whatnot that was you I think
yeah that was me Billy Idol yeah the
aisles I saw Billy Idol and I was like
it's it yeah there you go
yeah kind of had a Elvis quality to him
you know he was recognized at Elvis and
[ __ ] so I kind of saw him is like the
punk rock Elvis even though he's British
yeah but like he was taking it to an
even modernized he modernized it you
know it was kind of like that rebel
mentality yeah yeah it was always kind
of interesting to me how a lot of punk
and post-punk bands and artists strictly
from Britain and Australia really dug
like a lot of stuff from the American
South the old country and simply I mean
look at [ __ ] Nick
for Christ's sake you just loved like
all the old like Mississippi Delta blues
and all that it's totally idle loved
Elvis yeah that's what I mean so it's
just kind of interest and it was
interesting to see their like
interpretation interpretation of it yeah
he got it right yeah I mean I never got
like what it was I never got the vibe
that anybody was like kind of faking it
or anything no although I will say and I
don't know why I was thinking about this
the other day I was thinking about do
you remember there was um like for some
time like pretty during the new wave
period with all the British bands
everything for like the early 80s like
82 or something there was kind of a
thing in the UK of like white boy soul
you know what I mean where he had like
bands like ABC and lay the blue monkeys
and stuff like that yeah really yeah
Rick rollin [ __ ] so [ __ ] was
funny
I literally like that song I didn't know
if that was a white dude singing that no
I don't think anybody and then I saw a
video says wait a minute a little boy a
little white boys he look at a little
boy he look like a girl girl baby face
yeah and he was a ginger yeah black dude
Rick Astley well that's always so well
that was like even if that was a joke
even at the time like as I think some
people heard the song like radio in the
radio first and then you saw the video
and you're like wait yeah yeah and then
for a while like I don't know if anybody
ever speculated that it was like a Milli
Vanilli situation where no no it wasn't
like that was that actual dudes voice it
was just like really funny that nobody
expected little British can this little
pale ginger kid okay like had a voice
like that it was like really amazing
it's kind of sad I mean I guess he's
it's not really sad because like people
still know who he is like all these many
years later but I feel like that was
kind of like what is only hit I mean he
had a couple other hits to like I don't
remember them but I mean I mean I
remember him having more than one
probably in the UK he had a lot more
because I think that happened a lot back
then but yeah I do feel like there was
there was kind of a time period in there
where there was just kind of like this
really white
you know like kind of all these white
British bands that we're doing like that
sort of like soul like R&B type of thing
like with all the saxophones and
everything and for some reason I was
thinking about that the other day I
guess cuz I heard a song that reminded
me of that ABC song that I can't
remember the name of right now but
that's I don't know why I was thinking
of that yeah yeah I remember Paul Young
yeah yeah man I don't believe in tearing
down any statues I don't believe in
tearing them down now I believe in
putting statues up well yeah and I you
can relocate them but I don't believe
and destroy them and you know if if a
lot of the statues a lot of the stuff
that a lot a lot especially in the south
is kind of just irrelevant it's not
really relevant to the modern era and
like you look at it and you don't really
know who that is so I don't think you
know I mean the people that put it up or
long dead yeah it doesn't mean you
should destroy it but I don't see
anything wrong with maybe like moving it
to a different part of town if it's kind
of a meaningless statute it's not that
big and for some reason it's in the
center of the town and the new
inhabitants are like what the [ __ ] is
this you know and why not move it over
and move it somewhere else and put
something that they like there you know
I believe in adding adding statues yeah
I don't restore the old ones I mean some
of those things but this works of art
its art I don't believe in destroying
any art now some people would be like
well that's like Nazi stuff I don't even
really believe in destroying that Nazi
art I know some of the [ __ ] was huge and
they just they just had to get rid of it
so yeah nobody had a working forehead
room for this yes I understand that but
I didn't believe in [ __ ] purged and
out all that stuff that stuff all belong
in museums you know well in a way having
it in a museum at least people can go
and they can remember yeah what you know
what that was like and it's like hey
let's not do that yeah they were well I
look at it this way they're getting
emotional
alright and they're destroying something
that's not old it's it's only a few
years old they're getting emotional
about it but one day that [ __ ] will be
old imagine if you had statues original
original statues of jingis khan or
Attila the Hun those weren't good guys
but damn a statue of him would be worth
a lot of [ __ ] money yet because it
would it be so long I guess there's no
long as arrived yet and it's the same
thing with Roman emperors most of those
Roman emperors their statues don't exist
anymore we don't know what they look
like yeah and some of those Roman
statues we had them for [ __ ]
centuries before we figured out who they
were so I don't believe in destroying
any statues because time overtime
everything becomes value valuable yeah
if someone made it sure right yeah so I
don't believe in restoring anything
maybe moving it but not destroying it
yeah I would rather they just you know
they could just move it move it or make
another statue or put it in a museum
somewhere put in a collection or
something
yeah blue-eyed soul INXS did it - yeah
that's right they did I for some reason
I was like thinking of I don't know why
I was thinking at ABC for chrissake but
that was just what what occurred to me
and then I was thinking of that remember
that song by the blue monkeys digging
your scene these were played at I bar
sometimes I think that came out 86 and I
remember that guy he had a like a real
sharp suit and everything like that
[Laughter]
all right where you are you done talking
about you see what you're saying
cuz I just like I said I just came on
today because we needed to come on today
yeah to have something right I didn't
really have anything in particular to
talk about yes rick astley greatest of
all time I had other hits didn't he yeah
and yeah and he is a good guy he's real
he walked away from show business he got
so big he just couldn't handle it and he
was he wanted to be a father to his kids
so he just kind of left but he's been
doing stuff recently he had several hits
I thought he did yeah cuz I mean that
was like his biggest hit but I'm sure he
had at least a couple more in the u.s.
you know what I mean and I kind of feel
like in a way that the fame that he
achieved that's kind of a double-edged
sword because I do feel like I don't
know like he was really famous at the
time I'm like back then and then
everyone kind of forgot about him and
then the internet came along and then
brick Rowling became a thing and then he
like a meme yeah and then I feel like he
became like so much more famous than he
was back then that it's like could he
even [ __ ] go anywhere anymore without
everybody being like hey were being
rickrolled except like in person because
they're here it grows people did you
know that yeah yeah those showed okay no
he loves retro he understands
rickrolling he thinks it's hilarious
he and he said it was also kind of a
thing of luck that it would have been
somebody yeah it was just interesting to
sadly be him
so they'll hire him to rick roll an
event they had one where um had some
floats going down one of these parades I
can't remember which parade it was yeah
he said he's a DJ Mannix's rick rolled
the Macy's parade parade oh so that is
great stop he jumped out started singing
this Prachanda yeah like he's recognized
a man that kind of his voice is totally
recognizable yeah sounds just like that
they hired every rick roll all kinds of
this hill rick roll of the concerts but
like a show Thunder can't went running I
she's like oh [ __ ] I thought that weight
was falling on her yeah yeah the certain
bands I'll have him as a guest and they
will have him rick roll the audience so
they're playing i'll sudden it stops and
he comes out and it sinks never gonna
what's the call never gonna give you up
never gonna give you up ya know how did
it happen that it was that song in
particular was it just like rings on the
internet somebody came up with something
called duck rolling yeah that's yeah
yeah duck roll and duck rollin was some
kind of program that would replace egg
with the word duck and somebody said egg
roll but it came out duck roll and then
he sped to make me but that roll and
then they flipped it around they turned
duck rolling into Rick rolling because
when you press to the lake instead of it
going to a duck roll [ __ ]
looking at that song would come on and
then that started becoming rickrolling
it just it evolved into that yeah Rick
roller Graham Townsend says I'd rather
have a sausage roll yeah all right um
yes you guys got any questions or
anything for us we're probably set off
here somebody said somebody said two
dollars and said will Maxwell come to
trial I think it said did you see that
oh well [ __ ] man that little blue bar
trying to get Nostra Thomas to predict
well yeah that's what they sent a
donation to get Nostradamus as
predictions I don't have enough
information at this point it depends on
where she's being held and what kind of
Bartok bodyguards she has if she was
given some real [ __ ] good private
bodyguards I wouldn't trust any
government bodyguard if she had some
good private bodyguards and they had her
under proper surveillance maybe they can
keep her alive I have a feeling she's
not in a prison I think she's in a house
somewhere and in Goodkin you know in
really nice conditions so I think she's
probably out like an ankle bracelet on
probably a bunch of private guards she's
probably talking and they're recording
it but it wouldn't surprise me if the if
there's a very few investigators
involved that way there's no leaks
because you wouldn't want they wouldn't
want the subjects are the people that
they're talking about to find out what
information she's given up so she's
probably given up information
it's just that only a very few people
know what that information is I have a
weird feeling we will never know much
about this case I just that's my first
hunch I think a lot of this shit's gonna
be buried because a bunch of names are
gonna come up and
it's gonna be a long process of bringing
all these contusions to trial and to
charge all these people and to get them
to all roll over on one another I think
it'll take a good ten years to [ __ ]
unravel all that you have some people
that are thinking oh they're gonna
figure this out weeks and there's gonna
be indictments coming down and all these
people locked up and this is gonna help
Trump win the election now this shit's
gonna take years and years and years
well everything like not always takes
there's never like an yeah that's not
what it's gonna be
and most of that [ __ ] we will probably
never find out about it'll be something
kind of like the JFK assassination where
we know something happened where you
know they're still talking about yeah
yeah some happen we don't really we'll
never really know um
it's bad [ __ ] I'll tell you that though
sex cults see there's that nexium sex
cult - yeah yeah we did a show about it
and um it's like Scientology yep with a
sex club now this this child Island this
and child Island man and everything has
come out about this and then the
pitchers jig is lane Maxwell put up of
herself she's reading a book that has to
do with CIA spies so there's all these
signals that she put out while she was
kind of on the run if she was on the run
I'm not sure she was on the run I think
she was talking for a long time I think
this is part of an act this is part of
the Intel community it could be that
child Island man who did not kill
himself or who did not take his own life
could be that he was kind of like a
private contractor for multiple
intelligence agencies where they would
pay him for information and they could
buy dirt off of him because evidently
that child island was [ __ ] rigged
with bunch of cameras in order to join
his little [ __ ] mafia you had to have
sex with those beautiful young girls and
get that on tape and that was assurance
that you wouldn't betray them it was
like a
like a oath of loyalty because they had
this dirt on you and if you wanted to
make a lot of money that's how you
joined that gang wouldn't surprise me at
[ __ ] you know there's lots of them
that nexium might have been one of them
there's probably other ones we don't
know about yeah I wouldn't surprise we
see used to be back in the day the CIA
and intelligence agencies what they
would do is if they would if they could
if they could get you on can they would
they would put cameras inside of
brothels that they would run and you'd
have sex with these hookers in there and
then they'd approach and they said we're
gonna tell your wife that you were
screwing her if you don't do it we say
that's where this started but that
doesn't work anymore you know what I
mean
even for a while they were doing it like
we know you're gay they ran all the gay
clubs say so they'd get pictures of
powerful guys and says we're gonna tell
everybody you're gay if you don't do it
we say that doesn't work anymore so what
you have to do now to get to control
somebody it's got to be something
involving children that's why it went
that far because just a society changed
it has to be taboo you know adultery and
gay stuff isn't taboo anymore so it has
to be pedophilia that's why I went that
way and it may be even worse I'm is
rumored that what do they do with these
kids they kill these kids and when
they're done with them the German
authorities were giving out little kids
to pedophiles this there's almost
there's a bit riot in Germany over this
they've been doing it for 40 or 50 years
basically kind of like selling selling
orphans to pet to known pedophiles they
thought that that was some kind of
loving relationship would be fine but
the buzz so that's that what they were
convincing them so I think it had more
to do with money what makes you wonder
you know how kids were disappeared from
middle from Eastern Europe and disaster
zones and they were evacuated places by
the UN and children came up missing some
children came up missing and what was
that Jamaica nor what world was that
recently might have been one of those
islands out there
was it Puerto Rico I forgot but there's
one of those islands I had a big
hurricane hit it and some kind of a
child rescue center took the kids and
never never brought him back the parents
still want him back and they were they
were saying that Hillary Clinton was to
blame that's the last I heard was even
though she didn't do it but in some way
she was like involved with that kind of
like a rescues you know I don't remember
exactly how it wasn't real enough about
it but you know are they selling kids
well and why sex slaves the internal
organs what is it they want there's a
bunch of [ __ ] going on in China you know
the main [ __ ] rich people can get
internal organs from China it's probably
coming out of those wiegert's in those
concentration camps and prisoners you
know it's bad [ __ ] going on they're
trying to keep it quiet
well we had a couple questions I just I
wanted to get to them before they before
they leave um somebody asked have you
guys talked about the Golden State
killer in his plea deal I don't remember
if I oh thank you mangu badger thank you
um I don't remember if we mentioned it
but he did actually he's doing a plea
deal where he's gonna plead guilty to a
number of cases just you know so he
doesn't have to go to trial and all that
other kind of [ __ ] I think we mentioned
it but I don't remember if we did so if
you didn't I just didn't mention it Alex
Rivera asks can you guys explain what
drew you to goth music I'm curious what
about the sound that interested you as
opposed to the fashion and the broader
culture that's actually a really good
question um let's see I'm not sure what
it was about the sound in particular um
when I was a kid I guess most of the
music that I liked like because like I
said my dad was really into like a lot
of 60s stuff he liked the doors and the
Beatles and everything and so I started
listen to that when I was really young
and I was always just really attracted
to stuff that sounded kind of dark or
you know what I mean that was like kind
of sad or like kind of like ominous
sounding there's just something about
that sound that I always really liked so
when I got a little bit older and
started hearing you know sort of like
goth II type stuff in the early 80s I
was immediately like on
bored with that because that was just to
me it just seemed like an extension of
like you know creepy [ __ ] like the doors
like the doors kind of stuff and all
that so you know that's probably why I
just I was I guess it's like some kind
of weird genetic thing I'm just like
really attracted to ominous sounding
music I guess I started off listening to
early metal yeah yeah I made you just
pretty stuff from like you know very
early 80s and then as the eighties
progressed I also listen to punk rock
though to elect punk rock you listen to
like exploited and [ __ ] sex pistols
and Dead Kennedys but most of it most of
what I listen to his metal but as metal
went on you know especially towards
around 86 87 it started to get very
commercial and very female oriented with
like Bon Jovi and some of the newer kind
of like well the hair metal hair metal
and I just kind of it was getting away
from its roots
well I found sit as a mercy and Bauhaus
and that sent me down more the goth
direction started finding like you know
mmm cure albums and Suzie and it was it
was it Conor it was more honest that
wasn't commercial I liked it
Billy Idol even though that was
commercial it still kind of had that
goth Punk Conor with a rock flavor to it
started to appreciate more of like you
know Duran Duran and u2 and the Cure I
liked that the early I mean particularly
probably if I had to pick a favorite
genre I guess would probably be
post-punk just because yeah it is gonna
do well because it embodies like such a
huge I mean I think people forget like
you had punk rock which I really really
like but but you know a division in
stuff but yeah but I mean punk had such
a like a specific sound to it and I
think like if you've listened to enough
of it kind of got say me but after you
know Punk kind of died down then you got
like all these bands like just doing all
this different [ __ ] and like just you
just getting influences from everywhere
from
all different kinds of music and you
know even other like you know other
things like theater and [ __ ] like that
and so I think that it was a lot more
creative so um you know it's just a
sound either it was also just the
[ __ ] subject matter yeah because I
think a lot of metal particularly when
it started going in the hair metal
direction I didn't really like that it
was just all yeah like like DJ main
access but Rock where it was just kind
of like you know it's about I think
about how awesome they were all the time
about girls hire some girls and booze
and cherry pies yeah it's just really
really superficial really really
commercial yeah dumb dumb dumbs down
[ __ ] that's what I mean it's like that's
kind of why cuz that was like when I was
in junior high and so if and I was like
into new wave and everything that was
like what what dumb jocks listen to it
was just super dumbed down because
everything was just like they were the
the actual the content of the music the
subject matter actually was like very
much kind of like 50s rock and roll yeah
it's very very superficial cars girls
boy and me girl yeah yeah nothing to it
yeah it was very much like 50s rock yeah
different take on it and then some of
the guys you know like [ __ ] anvil and
cookie man award [ __ ] like it they would
try to there they were taking [ __ ]
hyper-masculinity to new levels where
their [ __ ] sing songs about Mothra
thank God I'm blowing you up with a
submarine
you know just that's that's that's just
like something like five five years ago
yeah we're in a submarine Godzilla's
gonna be yeah I mean you know and or
[ __ ] funny man but it wasn't meant to
be funny I know but that's it well
that's what like I I have never felt
like such a roller coaster of emotions
as I felt like when we watch that
documentary we get to watch that again
because like I felt like I wanted to
laugh at them but then I felt so sorry
for them that I felt like it asked
for laughing it's like for not because
they were just so like not self-aware
the funny thing about anvil is that
anvil was not that different from the
other bands that were making it it yes
it's just that if you get it just wrong
yes something wrong it becomes extremely
cringy yeah more cringy than the
competition and the competition was kind
of cringing yeah okay I can go back and
go listen to like a Black Sabbath album
that had Ronnie James Dio sing and I
think I could sing like [ __ ] crazy
and his lyrics were really good until
you really paid attention to him it was
like the Deepak Chopra where he would
[ __ ] let's say some wizard leash it
contradicted itself sounded like he said
some serious [ __ ] but he didn't he
didn't say anything you know like the
outside is the inside in the never that
always is see I just made that [ __ ] up
off the top of my head not some [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what [ __ ] Ronnie James he
put that in the song when you're 15 and
smoking dope
it was [ __ ] I can go back and listen
to it if I can enjoy it but go and go
you know that's some crazy lyrics yeah
like something out of tenacious d yeah
you're the movie Tenacious D but I love
that movie they were fun though it's
like and I like I liked like the older
metal like you said like Iron Maiden
than Judas Priest and something like
that I mean it's like I said it's not my
not my favorite cuz like I said even
some of the lyrics are kind of cringing
but yeah you know now you take that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] cringe Man O'War [ __ ]
anvil all right Ronnie James Dio you
compare those lyrics to like the lyrics
office such as a mercy first and last
and always
yeah it's no comparison there's really
not even even [ __ ] Andrew eldritch
could not top those lyrics again that
was it that's the best one of the best
albums of all times first and last and
always
well like I said I think that a lot of
had to do with the lyrics and the time
yeah and I well I think what it's what
attracted me to it was that was that
it's you know what I mean the lyrics
were a lot more intelligent they were a
lot more you know they made like a lot
of references like literary references
and cultural references and stuff like
that which you know some of the other
music didn't make so you know I can see
why it wasn't everyone's cup of tea
obviously but I you know that's probably
one of the reasons that I related so
much to you he said I made it just a
silly
I made this silly iron made no every
song is a topic and it's always about a
book or some [ __ ] that happened it's
like in history if I can I are made and
even though I love Iron Man Iron Maiden
well I'll just put it this way I love
Iron Maiden's like first four or five
albums but Iron Maiden is [ __ ] thinks
it's your history professor and it's
always high school history yeah yeah
yeah yeah
CJ maniac says we have a song called
Phantom of the Opera it's about the
Phantom of the Opera
they had a song called Genghis Khan it's
about Jake
song called Aces High it's about aces
then fly high Vala Britain okay yeah had
a song called where he goes there it's
about a movie called where he goes yeah
I know everything's very literal yeah
yeah yeah which I think like I said
that's a bother and like I said Angela's
doing that too like they were like
legitimately way a song when you maater
and yeah but when you put anvil next to
iron mid-iron min outclassed endl so it
just just goes to show you that just a
slight change in that yeah you really
fall on your [ __ ] face yeah there's
that there's a really like theater of
like awesomeness and there's like very
easy to like kind of follow Maidan was a
band of its of its time I the misfits
did the same damn I was just about to
say that exact thing like he just
basically they basically I like the
misfits but they did actually just write
songs about it but look we found this
like cheesy like 50s movie and they just
get a wrote a song about what happened
in it and they called it the same thing
is the movie
but I revisited I made in a couple
months back
and I still like the first two albums
with Paul D out or the best I think
then the ones with psyche in Bruce
Dickinson I think I still got a I think
I still like peace of mind the best yeah
yeah I don't didn't like numbers of the
beasts every one of those songs is like
filler on it the only one only song I
really that really kind of [ __ ] stood
the test of time on number the beast
even though every song on it's kind of
good but it's in a way it's kind of like
commercial filler hallowed be thy name
is still the best song on that one yeah
some might say [ __ ] powerslave but
peace of mind had still kind of had this
gothic metal kind of underground feel to
it for a while yeah yeah but I'm not to
say maybe [ __ ] the bet their best out
of his killers which has had Paul
Di'Anno on it that out I'm still [ __ ]
really good [ __ ] yeah I hear I hear
it like blasted yeah so yeah but yeah I
mean you know as far as lyrics go you
can't really I don't I just I don't know
I like impressionistic lyrics I don't
like lyrics there to like on the nose I
like ones that are kind of more poetic
and they're open to interpretation yeah
as opposed to ones that are just like
hey I'm watching a movie about a giant
monster and they're doing this and then
the other thing you know what I mean oh
right anything else yes Maiden live
shows are full of that guys know I kind
of laughter what because CGI maniac said
we have a song phantom of that but make
a man who says what's murders in the Rue
Morgue about then oh yeah and then Jay
Jay maniac says about eight and a half
minutes yeah I think I think we're going
to talk about irony out of Iron Maiden's
catalogue I still think Killers is the
best one yeah maybe not so much tech
technically in certain in terms of like
musical technicality but just in terms
of like tone I think Killers is still
the best one yeah yeah I don't know
enough about Iron Maiden
like agree or disagree with you that
that was their second one so I'm just
going to acquiesce everyone shows up in
a mating show wearing amazing shirt yeah
yeah it's like don't be that guy yeah
what was yeah
goddamnit when that kids in the hall I
think it was kids in the hall I can't
remember now because I remember when I
was in high school that was the rule you
went to a show you weren't allowed to
wear the shirt of that band at that show
and it's like if somebody did that like
if you were going to pick up your
friends to go to the show and they had
this shirt or like don't be that guy
don't be go change your shirt right now
we're not being with you you know that
was kind of another one that kind of
over time
kind of I thought kind of made a lot of
mistakes was Judas Priest their last
good album if you asked me I mean guys
are gonna just disagree with me but I
think their last good album was
defenders of the faith really and I like
their 70 stuff feather like sin after
sin after sin and sad wings of Destiny
maybe like stained glass you know
but I think that was their their best
out well I don't know screaming for
vengeance was a pretty [ __ ] good
album but as it went on you know it
[ __ ] turbo I think turbo was [ __ ]
not a very good album and it just seemed
to get worse and worse and then people
like that painkiller album and it never
really impressed me that much even
though I liked rob halford you know the
cool dude yeah I mean he always seemed
like a cool dude yeah
oh it's from PC oh oh it's from PC okay
I knew I had seen it somewhere the thing
about don't be that guy about wearing
the shirt to the I knew I had seen it
somewhere for some reason I thought it
was kids in the hall I don't know why I
guess because I was kind of in high
school or a little bit after high school
and we were always like making that joke
about people wanting to wear the [ __ ]
shirts even if you bought the shirt at
the show you weren't allowed to put it
on until later like next day because I'm
like don't be such a dork now you were
allowed if you went to see like for
example if you went to see like Peter
Murphy you could wear like a Love and
Rockets shirt that was allowed but you
couldn't you know what I'm saying yeah
although
he probably would have got mad he's an
[ __ ] yeah he's good life but yes yeah
I've seen him like a zillion yes he's
losing his mind he's got serious drug
problems he's deteriorating rapidly
[ __ ] throwing bottles at the crowd
and get kicked out of his own [ __ ]
shows and Shetty's yeah that was special
yeah if I could hit and run yeah and run
accidents and [ __ ] drugs or a hell of
a drug he's a meth head you burn him up
burnin which is a shame because it's
like I thought he was gonna go like the
more dignified Bowie route but I know
that's not in the cards
[ __ ] Bowie outclassed his ass so much
and Bowie held himself together him he
looked good till the day he died
that's what I'm thinking cancer any me
looked good looking now if I can
Murphy's fallen apart and that's sucks
because he had not that old not that old
but he looks old
yeah looks old looks very [ __ ] heads
[ __ ] all weazened up [ __ ] here all
falling out pot-bellied [ __ ] he
didn't when he was young he was very
skeletal you know and you can get away
with that for a while but as you get
older you just not producing the right
kind of hormones by not eating and you
start [ __ ] getting real pot-bellied
but funny-looking the only way to [ __ ]
hold yourself together is [ __ ]
exercising yeah because he wouldn't
exercise you cannot replicate that
skinny emaciated [ __ ] heroin 16 year
old look that he wanted to have yeah do
that it feels super hot back in the day
yeah and you can't do that in the 50 you
can't do that your fifties no well I'm
sure I'm not gonna say anybody you only
got two choices you're going you can get
fat or you're gonna have to get muscular
one of the two you've got to start
regulating your hormones man that's
where it's at yeah you can't regulate
hormones without [ __ ] doing anything
you can't just sit there and do meth and
do math destroy all your [ __ ]
testosterone probably [ __ ] up your even
your estrogen balance and then it'll
[ __ ] do weird [ __ ] do you
progesterones and
[ __ ] up your saline your electrolytes
you got a deuce [ __ ] and your
preservative it's just you're either
[ __ ] growing or you're shrinking it's
one of the two once you get once you get
into your 50s yeah I want to shrink down
the Smurfs yes yeah maybe I'll live long
enough
well it's Quinn yeah we've been I can't
believe him ago for an hour and I was
sitting there gone I don't even know
what the [ __ ] we're gonna talk about
yeah that's all right so uh thanks you
guys for dropping by today we'll
probably go on a little bit tomorrow too
if I can find a new movie tonight we can
review a new movie tomorrow so I'll make
that my mission for this evening so we
will talk to you guys again tomorrow and
I'm looking a little fat lady yeah I'd
look a little fat ladies lately
[Laughter]